تمتعنا بالصبر فالفشل جزء من الحياه
الطبيعيه
وستكون وستكوني بخير هذه هي رساله السباحه
السوريه اللاجئه يسرى مارديني لكل نساء
العالم وخاصه اللاجئات منهن
نجاحات عديده حققتها مارديني منذ بدايه
مشوارها لعل ابرزها المشاركه في
الاولمبياد والتي لخصها في
نتفليكس هذا الفيلم بالفعل ساعد في ترويج
قصتها للعالم وقصه الملايين من اللاجئين
الذين ركبوا سفن الموت للوصول الى بر
الامان
ماردينيا تدرس الاخراج والانتاج في لوس
انجلوس وهي سفيره النوايا الحسنه لدى
مفوضيه اللاجئين ومع اقتراب الاحتفال
باليوم العالمي للاجئين الذي يصادف
العشرين من الشهر الحالي في فنجان قهوه
لليوم نستضيف يسرا مارديني للحديث اكثر عن
حياتها مشاريعها
المقبليه معنى الان مشاهدينا في الاستوديو
السباحه الاولمبيه يسرا مارديني اهلا بك
يا يسرا معنا صباح الخير صباح الخير تفضلي
انا سعيده جدا انه انا عم بقابلك شخصيا
الحقيقه فيلم
اللي عن قصتك الملهمه والمؤثره جدا كان
واحد من افضل من الافلام المفضلين لالي
بالفعل وللدرجه انه يعني ما قبلتش الا
اطفالي كمان يحضروا معي حتى يشوفوا هاي
القصه الملهمه طيب يسرا بين كل اللي صار
الخروج من سوريا السباحه الوصول
للاولمبياد اين انت الان
هلا عم بدرس بصراحه عم ادرس اخراج انتاج
باميركا
لساتني عم بشتغل مع اليو ان المفروض
اللاجئين بشكل عام كمان عندي مشاريع
لاعمل سبورت للاجئين بالرياضه وبالتعليم
لدعم اللاجئين في مجال الرياضه حتى لا
تقولي عنا بخلاء احنا خلينا نشرب هذا
الفنجان من
القهوه الصباحيه اول شيء كيف بتحبيها
دايما
مره مره اه بدون
شكرا جزيلا العادي خليني اسالك بانه
اتفضلي شكرا حارة فنجان قهوه لازم يكون في
قهوه بهاي الفقره خليني اسالك بانه تعرفت
على يسرى اكثر كما قلنا من الفيلم لكن
اليوم كان عندنا
محور بانه ايهما اكثر
التحملا للخساره الرجل ام المراه اي اكثر
اقدام وجراه الرجل ام المراه صراحه بيعتمد
على الرجل اول مره لانه في في رجال اقوى
من النسوان وفي نسوان
انا كنت اقوى من الرجل صراحه بابا اللي
علمني كيف اكون قويه
فهو حسب العيله وحسب كيف ربانيين يعني
وانا برايي اثنين فينا يكون والفتاه قادره
يعني انت واختك كسرتوا كل القواعد وكل هذه
الافكار النمطيه
وسبحتوا الى بر الامان فعليا وحرفيا بس
اللي علمنا بابا وماما
مفوضيه اللاجئين شو بالضبط خصوصا هذا
المجال اللي انت مهتمه فيه اللي هو مجال
الرياضه مع انك عم تدرسي اشي مختلف الان
وكيف ناويه انك تدعمي اللاجئين تحديدا في
هذا المجال
بشكل عام نحن انا شغله مع المفوضيه
انا متحدثه بحكي القصه وبحكي شو صار معي
كلاجة بروح على
كامبات نروح مثلا على الزعتري على الازرق
وبشوف اللاجئين مخيمات لاجئين في الاردن
مثلا او في لبنان
بكل العالم
وبنحكي مع اللاجئين نسمع قصصهم ونشوف شو
هن لازم نشوف الشي نحن فينا نخليه احسن
لانه هنا عايشين بمخيم بالاخير اه وصارلي
هلا سفيره معهم صار لي من وقت ما كان عمري
هي متعبه انه تكوني مصدر الهام لغيرك هل
في هذا العمر وانت في عز شبابك تستطيعين
ان تكوني مصدر الهام اعطيتيه
الامل لهؤلاء الاطفال بانه يكونوا يسرى
مارديني فتيات على الاقل
ابحثي عن هذه طبعا ابحث على مين انا شو
يعني ليش انا صرت لاجئه ليش كان لازم اترك
بلدي لما وصلت على المانيا ورجعت بلشت
اسبح ورحت على الاولمبياد اول مره وتعرفت
على هالفريق اللي كان عشر اشخاص بس من كل
حوالين من كل انحاء العالم وكل حدا عنده
قصه تانيه
فكان عندي امل وكان عندي لاحظت انه عندي
صوت فهذا الصوت انا فيني استخدمه فيني مثل
ما انا اجاني فراس فيني امنح فراس لاجئين
اشتقت
فقررت انه اعمل هالشي طيب يسرى قصتك
مرتبطه بشكل وطيط مش بسمع اللجوء ومع
الرياضه ايضا ولكن انت قررتي هلا انه
توظفي صوتك بطريقه مختلفه عم تدرسي اخراج
واللي هو يعني شيء بعيد جدا عن الرياضه
ليه لانه فكرت انا كان بدي ادرس بس ما
قدرت ادرس لانه كنت عم بتمرن للاولمبياد
الثاني طوكيو
وبعدين
حسيت اني انا خسرت كثير من حياتي او
طفولتي وكان بدي خذ هاي التجربه كان بدي
اروح على الجامعه وكان بدي ادرس فكان هو
يا اعلام يا انتاج اخراج
فانا بحب اروي القصص انا بحكي قصتي فانا
بدي احكي قصه لاجئين حول العالم
وفكرت كيف فيني احكي القصص اعلام او اخراج
فيني احكي قصص هون فيني اعمل فيلم مثل
السباحه
العين المختلفه للمخرج او للمنتج وكذلك
للاجئه السابقه قاعده تشوفين الاوضاع
مختلفه
والله الاطلاله حلوه اليوم
عن جد فعلا وانه انت قررتي انه تظهري بهذا
مش باشي رياضي مثلا
راح تكون ممثله
هوليود ولا
اثنين ممكن ممكن
انا شايفها بعيونك وراح برضه تتالقي هيك
بلباس عربي كمان انه اخترتي انك تطلعي
بهذا الشكل
ونفتخر طيب اكيد شكرا جزيلا لك يسرا
مارديني السباح الاولمبيه كانت معنا في
الاستوديو في فنجان قهوه يسرا دائما كما
قيل لها ستقول ستتعب ولكن لن يكسركن احد
شكرا جزيلا شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد
ارجو القصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات